نتابع هذه الصور من محافظتي باجا وقفصه في
تونس وفيها وقفات احتجاجيه عماليه لمنتسبي
الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل تمديدا
باستهداف الحريات النقابيه هذا ليست تحرك
الاول طبعا الاسبوع الماضي شهد عدد من
التحركات
للاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل تمديدا
باعتقال قياديين في الاتحاد وايضا ما
يسمونه بقمع الحريات في تونس اذن
الاعتقالات طالت اطرافا عديده ليست فقط
اطرافا سياسيه معارضه وانما ايضا اطراف
صحفيه ومدنيه على مختلف المستويات هذه
المسيره اذا
الوقفه الاحتجاجيه هي من محافظتي باجه
وقفصه صحيح الاتحاد التونسي طبعا يقول بان
السياسه الاقتصاديه للرئيس قيس سعيد
لم تنقذ البلاد بل بانها ساعدت على تدهور
الامور الاقتصاديه في تونس وهذه احد
الامور التي يطالب فيها الاتحاد التونسي
للشغل بتغيير السياسه الاقتصاديه ونجى
الاقتصادي للرئيس قيس السعيد ولحكومته
ايضا